في عمليه نقلتها شاشات التلفزه القت اجهزه
الامن في ولايه ماسجوس القبض على المشتبه
فيه بالمسؤوليه عن اكبر عمليه تسريب
لوثائق سريه في الولايات المتحده خلال
الاعوام الماضيه
القت وزاره العدل القبض على جاك
دوجلاستيشيره في اطار تحقيقات الجاريه حول
الاستخراج غير المصرح به لمعلومات سريه
تتعلق بالدفاع الوطني والاحتفاظ بها
ونقلها تشيرا موظف في الحرس الوطني للقوات
الجويه وقد قام عملاء مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي باعتقال تشيره في وقت سابق من
بعد ظهر اليوم دون وقوع اي حوادث انتشار
يبلغ احدى عشرين سنه وهو اختصاصي في
التكنولوجيا المعلومات بوحده الاستخبارات
في الحرس الوطني لولايه مسدس وكان يعمل في
قاعده في ولايه نورث كارولاينا عندما شرع
في تسريب الوثائق
وفق تقارير اعلاميه
تشارع سرب الوثائق الى اعضاء غرفه دردشه
كان يديرها على منصه ديسكورد للمراسلات
المخصصه لهوات العاب الفيديو
وسبق لصحيفه واشنطن تحدثت الى عضو في غرفه
الدردشه المذكوره زعم ان المسرب كان يعمل
في قاعده عسكريه امريكيه دون ان يكشف عن
اسمه
هو ليس عميلا روسيا ولا اوكرانيا ولا
يتعاطف مع الشرق واي ادعاءات بانه عميل
روسي او مال لروسيا هي زائفه فهو ليس
مهتما بمساعده اي اجهزه امنيه ضد الولايات
المتحده او اي دول اخرى
يقول مصدر واشنطن بوست ان المسربه لم يكن
مدفوعا برغبه التبليغ عن اسرار حكوميه
انما كان مستاءا من تجاوزات الحكومه
الامريكيه
الكشف عن هويه المسرب قد لا يعني بالضروره
ان مسلسل افشاء الوثائق السريه بلغ حلقته
الاخيره فقد تظهر وثائق اضافيه من خبايا
منصه ديسكورد التي اكدت انها تتعاون مع
التحقيقات المتواصله فدي منصور الجزيره
واشنطن